Alright, Michael. What's the answer?
>> I think I've already made a mistake.
>> Okay. What's the mistake?
>> Suggesting that we do a quiz.
>> [LAUGH] I'm pretty sure that's always true. Unless
Michael, by doing a quiz now and suffering pain,
you, in the future, are a better person. In
which case, you have made the right long term decision.
>> I see. You're, this is a MDP metapoint you're making.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Alright. So let, but let's, let's just buckle down and do
this thing. So.
>> Okay.
>> Alright, so at that state x, we have
to consider, according to the equation, we're going to do
U sub one at x. And that's going to be
the reward at x, which is minus .04. Mm-hm.
>> Plus gamma, which is a half.
>> Yes.
>> Feel free to write these things down.
>> Okay, so, let's see. It's going to be minus .04 plus one half times.
>> Alright. So now we need to do four different actions.
>> Right.
>> So, I don, I would make like a brace-y
thing at this point. Not a bracket, but a brace. Alright?
>> Or I could do a bracket, because you're going to
notice immediately that it's obvious what the right action is.
>> Okay, alright. Well, we know that the, the
right action's going to be to go to the right.
>> Yeah, but even then, you know you don't
have to do the rest of the computation because my
first guess at all the utilities is
that they're 0. Which means you're always going
to want to take the action that gets you to plus one with the highest chance.
>> Right.
>> So there's just no point in.
>> I see. Okay. Fair enough. Thank you for.
>> Okay.
>> The shortcut. So, so we only have to
do the one action which is to the right.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so if we go to the right,
there's three possible next states we could go in.
>> Yeah.
>> One is back to x, which has a value of zero.
>> Mm-hm.
>> One is to the thing underneath of x, which has a value of zero.
And then the last one with probability 0.8 needs to go to the plus one.
>> Which is.
>> 0.8 times plus one.
>> Which is 0.8.
>> 0.8.
>> Okay. And that is?
>> Okay. So 0.8 times a half is 0.4 minus 0.04 is 0.36.
>> Yep. And that is correct.
>> Okay, so to
do the same thing for you too, we're going to need the
U1 value for a bunch of other states, seems to me.
>> Maybe, so let's right that down. So we
know for now the utility here is .36 right?
>> Yeah.
>> And you're saying that in order to do U two,
I'm now going to have to, you know, I was able to avoid
doing some of the math before because, these are all zeroes.
So it was just easy to do. But when I went right,
I either stayed where I was, went to the
plus one, or I ended up going down. Well I
think by the same argument that allowed us to cheat
our way out of to cheat our way out before.
>> Okay,
>> It's still going to be best to go to the right, so.
>> Yeah but I know that but the value itself
is going to depend on the value in several other states.
>> Yeah well how many other states?
>> Oh, just that one.
>> Just this one,
so what was U one of this state? I see. So, presumably, we want to avoid falling
into the pit, so the, the best thing we
can do is bash our head against the wall,
>> Mm-hm
>> Which will get us a -.04 for that statement.
>> Right.
>> Okay, alright, so maybe this isn't so, so bad.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So now for our u2 values we need -.04
plus a half times point, point one times point 36. Plus.
>> Mm-hm.
>> 0.1 times negative 0.04, so that's minus 0.004,
plus 0.8 times one. Oh, which is 0.8 again, just like it was last time.
>> Yep.
>> And I get 0.376.
>> Which is what I get by also getting
out your calculator. Okay, so 0.376, and you can imagine
how we would do that on and on. I want
to point something out, Michael, which is that. You decided
to figure what the true utility was for the
state under X by bashing your head into the
wall. But you know that based on the discussion
we had earlier that actually the optimal policy would involve
going up instead of bashing your head into the
wall. What you did at that point was in
fact right because everything else in this utilities were
all zero. The best thing you could do is avoid
getting, avoid ever falling into minus one, so the policy
of the very first of bashing your head into the
wall, is infact the right thing to do at that
point. But what youll notice is that next time around
the utility for the X state Is bigger than zero.
In fact, will keep getting bigger and bigger than zero.
As you can see, it went from .36 to 0.376.
Which means that at some point it's going to be worthwhile
to try to go up instead of bashing your head into a wall.
>> I see. So this, so this is kind of cool that it
works. But, it does seem like a really roundabout way of getting there.
I mean, is there some way that we could some, I don't
know, maybe take advantage of the fact that there's not that many policies?
>> Yeah, so you actually said something, fairly
subtle there, so let's see if we can
unpack it. So, lemme point out two things, which I think will get us to what
you're answering. The first is. Do you realize
that the reason that the value iteration works is
because eventually value propagates out from its neighbors,
right? The first time we can calculate the .36
without really worrying about anything around it because
the utilities are all zero, and in fact, based
on the initial utilities. Even for this state
here, we do the wrong thing. But after some
time, this state becomes a truer representation of its utility
and, in fact, gets higher and higher. The right thing to
do here will go up. You'll also notice that after
another time step I'm going to need to start looking at
the value of this state as well. Alright. So, eventually
I'm going to have to figure out the value, the utilities
or the values of all of these states and this
plus one is going to propagate out towards the other states.
Where this minus one will propagate out less because you're going to try
to avoid falling in there. So that
makes sense, right? But what's propagating out,
Michael? What's propagating out is the true utilities, the true values of these
states. But what's a policy? A policy is a function from what to what?
>> States to actions.
>> Right, a policy is the mapping from
state to action. It is not a mapping from
states to utilities.
>> No, that's what U is.
>> That's what U is.
>> Or that's what you are.
>> So, [LAUGH], so if we have U, we can figure out pi, but U
is actually much more information than we need to figure out pi. If we have a
U that is not the correct utility, but
say, has the ordering of the actions correct,
then we're actually doing pretty well, right? It
doesn't matter whether we have the wrong utilities.
>> I see. Uh-huh.
>> You'll remember
we did this in the, the first third of the class
as well when we noticed that we were computing in the
Bayesian learning case actual probabilities. But we don't really care about
actual probabilities. We just care that the labels are right. There's
a very similar argument here. We don't care about having the
correct utilities, even though by having the correct utilities, we have
the right policy. All we actually care about is getting the
right policy. And order matters there rather than absolute value. Does that
make sense?
>> Yeah, that's interesting. It's almost kind of like pi
is more of like a classifier, right? It's mapping. Inputs
to discreet classes and the user kind of like, more
like regression where its mapping these states to continuous values.
>> Right and given one, given the utilities, we
can find pi, given pi there's an infinite number
of utilities that are. Consistent with it. So, what
you end up wanting to do is get a utility
that's good enough to get you to your pie. Which is one reason why you don't
have to worry about getting the absolute convergence
in [UNKNOWN]. But it gives us a hint of
something we might do that's a little bit
better with the policies that might go faster
in practise. So, I'm just going to take three
seconds to give you an example of that. Okay?
>> Awesome.